was bleibt wenn ein künstler stirbt eine
weiße leinwand nichts
seine bilder ideen erinnerung
als fritz kurz vor 25 jahren starb
hinterließ er über 300 ölbilder
aquarelle bühnenbild entwürfe grafiken
ein pralles server dass er seiner
tochter und seinem schwiegersohn
anvertraute die sich seither um das erbe
kümmern
es sind nicht nur einfach bilder ein
jedes weckt gefühle erinnerungen wie
geht man damit um
ist so ein erbe freude oder last kann
man es loslassen
die ehrensberger haben sich pepe vom
meisten verabschiedet übrig geblieben
sind nur noch die bühnenbild entwürfe
für mehr als 130 inszenierungen in ganz
europa sie sind ein stück von ihm vom
vater von fritz weniger mir weniger herz
gewachsen sind
das will ich das jetzt einfach nicht
unbedingt einfach auf das ganze internet
sind das statt proxy längere zeit gut
gemacht und dann fangen wir also dass
kommen aber nicht nur darüber statt
das war das glück sei nun lagern die
bilder hier in der galerie tesoro in
altendorf von vater und sohn geführt
sie haben sich spezialisiert auf
nachlässe von schweizer künstlern
früherer generationen also ein großer
teil unserer aufgabe besteht darin dass
micron vorletzte generation eine neue
generation präsentiert und im mitwisser
schmackhaft machen
und was da sehr wichtig ist das objekt
nicht nur einfach ein historischer wert
hand auszieht dokument sondern dass das
wirklich ein aktuell user geschafft hat
doch genau das ist auch das problem denn
der kunstmarkt verändert sich rasant
was gestern modern war wirkt heute
altmodisch bis zu zehn nachlässe werden
galerist uli eberhard im jahr angeboten
aber nur um einen kann er sich kümmern
sofern er chancen auf dem kunstmarkt
sieht denn so wie der künstler starb oft
auch sein publikum und neues interesse
muss erst geschaffen werden
das ist sehr viel arbeitet fotografiere
registriere runter ein umstellung zu
machen
publizieren und das machen wir ihre
motivation ist dass mehr da jetzt
wirkliche bis zehn frauen im bereich von
der schweizer maler sind nur schweizer
maler 20 320 runde
womit die typveränderung segantini und
giacometti bhb maler wo aber absoluten
anspruch zeigt weiter und weiter das
wissen weitergibt
mit fritz kann man eintauchen in eine
andere zeit
seine grafikentwürfe seine ersten
bühnenbilder die uraufführung von paul
burkhards der schwarze hecht all das ist
ein stück schweizer kulturgeschichte
auch wenn die bilder längst nicht mehr
die preise erzielen zu denen sie früher
verkauft wurden was nie verschwindet es
die persönliche erinnerung an einen
vielseitigen an einem künstler der bis
zuletzt malen musste der auf 1000
hochzeiten tanzte mit unglaublicher
leichtigkeit und es bleibt doch mehr
als eine weiße leinwand